[Music]
last week marked the 50th anniversary of
Star Trek the showing on the air
September 8 1966 now some sci-fi fans
who love Star Trek also loves Star Wars
but some fanatics say no you have to
choose one or the other one of those
fanatics is our associate producer
jordan shlonsky there he is
Jordan is obsessed with Star Wars he
thinks it's far superior to Star Trek
but here's the thing Jordan kind of
reminds me of Spock
the lack of emotion the robotic way of
speaking the absence of any behavior
that can remotely be considered human so
I thought it would be fun for us to
forrester him to dress up as Spock and
make him come out here and pay homage
homage to Star Trek and congratulate all
Trekkies on their fiftieth anniversary
he doesn't want to do it we're making
him do it because it's his job please
welcome Jordan slansky
[Music]
Jordan thank you very much for being
here like the spot costume now first of
all tell us why do you think Star Wars
is superior to Star Trek
well star track is granted in our own
frame of reference and as such suffers
from the limits of our own trite reality
in fact Star Wars delves more into the
worlds of fantasy and mythology and such
as on some Universal mythological themes
that have been present across humanity
since the beginning of time you'll find
that most cultures on earth share a
common mythology in fact the Greek
Odysseus was known as Ulysses in Rome
the Greek Zeus was known as Jupiter in
Rome the Greek Poseidon was known as
Neptune in roaming you're talking about
a story of a young farm boy from the
middle of nowhere that goes up against a
great oppressor and this story is common
in a lot of mythologies such as Davey
and Goliath then you'll find again that
this touches a core human emotion that
we all need to explore through a fantasy
world those concepts which we cannot
achieve in our own reality world now on
another note I find that the universal
worldwide acceptance of Star Wars is
also grounded in this commonality that
we all share instead of being limited
through one frame of reference through
one focal point we can see things in a
cross-cultural manner if you will and in
fact to expand on that a little bit I
think that you'll find that the Star
Wars universe is relatable for any
culture on earth any economic standing
any financial stand in or focus again
we're talking about themes that are core
to the concept of humanity in general
and emotional furthermore I can tell you
that the types of things that you're
talking about in Star Trek are limited
towards a certain set of circumstances
that it exists in almost a two
dimensional plane
we're in Star Wars you're really
exploring different feelings about
humanity happiness sadness all the
various spectrum modes of human
existence and I find that even though
you're talking about characters that are
often not human we as human beings can
identify through their struggles and
you'll find that most great storytelling
has to deal with a protagonist
an ordinary person up against
extraordinary odds and I think that if
you look at the literature across the
history of recorded time you'll find
that a lot of the greatest stories have
followed that same theme the storyline
is almost unimportant because you're
talking about grand
here about human achievement when faced
with unlikely odds and furthermore I can
tell you that beyond that it's something
that we can all agree upon it is all
something we can all identify with and
relatability I'm sure you know as
someone that works in the storytelling
world is a concept that is necessary to
have an audience invest themselves in
the story that you're telling I'll also
tell you that the Star Wars universe
while on some level is very exotic had a
musical soundtrack grounded in 19th
century romantic music and in fact I can
relate Star Wars the appeal of it
towards some of the great impressionist
paintings like the touch of an Hawk
because his paintings although not
photographic if you will or
photorealistic
inspired our own imagination to latch on
to the concepts present in the painting
and for example if you look at Bauhaus
starry night you'll see that again while
it doesn't necessarily look exactly like
a city and stars and the wind blowing
through the trees you can feel the
feeling of what it was like to be in
that situation you know unlike looking
at a photograph which again gives you
that two-dimensional representation that
split-second microsecond in time if we
will and yet as anyone knows that's had
a bad photograph taking them a split
second in time doesn't often represent
the whole picture
however when when you're talking about
the idea of a painting and certainly an
oil painting and impressionist oil
painting you're not necessarily
capturing all the minor details you're
capturing a feeling now how do you put a
feeling down on canvas how do you put a
feeling down on the screen well that's
the job of the artistic storyteller and
in fact the storyteller in this case
took his own human emotions his own
human struggles and that of others and
put them into a fantastic circumstance
which none of us could have possibly
experienced yet
can all take pride in relate to again
the young struggling farm boy wanting to
be a part of all these are things that
were touched upon in 1976 is rocky I'm
talking about the original Rocky
it wasn't about winning the fight that
movie is not a boxing movie that movie
is about an ordinary guy placed an
extraordinary certain business a guy he
was the underdog you know in other
common concepts you find a lot of
literature he was the underdog that
wanted a maked all he wanted to do
was go the distance he wanted to make it
to the Philadelphia spectrum it probably
has some corporate brands at name now
but at the time 1976 shot 1975 it was
called a Philadelphia spectrum these
theatres and arenas amphitheaters had
real names back then you know I think
Fenway Park is still named is such
Candlestick Park I'm sure has been
renamed I don't really follow sports
myself but I heard these terms said and
I know that a lot of the original like
Shea Stadium I think it's like Citibank
Field or something but that's not really
relevant to what I'm talking about here
but interesting nevertheless however
what I'm saying is that for an artist to
accurately portray a feeling on film or
canvas or whatever the medium I mean you
could be talking about a mounds of clay
really the artistic medium is irrelevant
when a singer gets up and sings you
don't care about the vocal chords
vibrating at certain frequencies you're
trying to take part in and relate to a
certain feeling that that artist is
trying to convey when a sculptor takes a
look at a hunk of mud and clears away
certain sections to make this great
monolith of art again it's not about the
minerals that are present in the mud
it's about the feeling that you're
trying to convey
you're fired
get the out of here and never come
back I thought you're gonna cut me off
at some hands so I just no no it doesn't
say I cut him off yeah no it doesn't say
I cut him off first of all that was
incredible performance it really was I I
was waiting for you to finish so that I
could say my line and didn't know I
thought that that was part of what they
had in mind was it he goes on for six
minutes I didn't know
[Music]
you